oh babe you had a crush on me that's
embarrassing we're married
still being nice made me feel terrible I
nominated you for this big award it's
called The International Coalition of
women in government and you
won there's like five winners and you
get a big trophy or something oh my God
this is real I I just assumed you were
lying thank you so how long do you think
you'll stay in Pony for I don't
know we like it here I made Andy promise
that someday we'll move to Transylvania
but that probably won't happen till
we're like a 100 well for what it's
worth I'm really happy that you and Andy
are married
why why because I love him and I love
you why wouldn't I be
happy I want too what's that I love to I
I couldn't I couldn't quite hear you
please don't make me say it
please my going away way present to you
will be that I do not make you ably say
that you love me thank
you okay Leslie's coming back get off me
wench did I miss a nice moment no yes
you did oh
good okay turn around what why because
I'm about to say something serious and I
can't do it if I have to look you in the
eye please
okay now I'll take your shoes off and
wear them like mitt April okay
sorry when I started working for you I
was
aimless and just thought everything was
stupid and lame
and you turn me into someone with goals
and ambition which is really the only
reason why I'm even thinking about what
I really
want and I just want to say thank
you and I love you very
much which is why I have decided not to
turn you into a sea urchin which I could
do because I am an actual witch with
powers and I'm evil and I hate
everything I know you do I'm
nervous babe look at me you were going
to pass this test and you going to
become a cop and if you don't I'll just
divorce you and marry someone else and
then cheat on them with
you oh it's so sweet also I got you a
lucky
charm I found a dead rabbit on the side
of the road and I cut its feet off and
made it into a lucky charm baby you are
so
creepy thank you I love
it
what
he Tom and an are on a date I know what
do you mean you know how do you know cuz
cuz I set them
up I was watching Ann with Tom at the
dance and she seemed to be having a good
time so I went over and talked to her
what are you looking for in a date
anyway I don't know what does anyone
want just a nice funny guy who likes me
and treats me well Tom's funny and he
treat you well ha ha I'm serious you
want a good date why not ask out the
only guy that's made you smile tonight
he he's ridiculous all that dumb Swagger
it's an act he's sweet you should just
ask him out for a drink I'm 1,000% sure
I'd say yes I bet you guys would have a
good
time man I need to like wrap my head
around this why it makes sense to me
this is a small loser Town loser people
and Tom's like at least semi cool you
know what I'm hearing you tried to make
Ann happy for Valentine's
Day you're a very nice person nice you
are very nice by think it's got to be
someone okay Ben you know that I despise
you and that I want you and all people
on Earth to be miserable right sure you
should be mayor you're the best person
for the job and you deserve it plus this
would erase IC town it's been torturing
you since you were 18 years old and if
you became mayor of Pon you could put it
behind you once and for
all being nice made me feel
terrible he said he wanted me to head up
the comp I have no idea how to run a
nonprofit hey you shine shoes for over 2
years and never made a
profit come on you can hack
this I believe in
you but to replace you I am going to
have to build a scarecrow replica of you
and take it to the movies seems like the
only logical
solution sorry I can't go through with
this I was going to pull a prank no yeah
I hired these guys and ski masks to
kidnap us and I was going to pretend to
be a hero they were going to shoot me
and drive the van into the river and
that's when the divers would go in pull
you guys out of the water and I would be
standing on the shore like hey get
pranked much what the I even got these
squibs from his special effects guy and
I was going to say this code word and
that's when I would push this button no
no
no oh my God God you got blood all over
me thank you I mean it Ben that was
amazing really best prank
ever I made a marshmallow Ron
Swanson gosh his arms are crossed
because he's mad at all the other
marshmallow workers for annoying him you
like
it it's fine when I was trying to um I
miss Andy and you probably miss your
lover Chris I had an idea it's Friday
Pony's only a 10-hour Drive road trip oh
I don't know I was going to try and get
a jump on some work this weekend dude 30
years from now when you're on your
deathbed what are you going to remember
organizing files or taking a spontaneous
road trip to surprise Leslie yeah you
know what all right I'm in you know we
might be able to sneak out early you get
snacks I'll bring music we'll jam out to
some sweet tunage you know what this is
awesome actually no I don't want to go
anymore oh okay just kidding see you in
10 minutes okay just just kidding we're
not
going road trip so we're going
yes hey hey are you leaving I just have
to get a jump start on my next phase
let's see it is 48h hour roadkill scrap
Aon oh brother okay well before you go I
have something for you I feel like
you're getting sad about how stupid and
lame people are and that is my job not
yours so I'm going to going to read this
letter to you out loud but if you hug me
afterwards I swear to God I'll scream
and pull my hair out and maybe punch you
in the face
okay okay please
sit dear award committee members Leslie
I didn't even start okay I'm
sorry go ahead dear award committee
members where I live there are a lot of
apathetic people people who don't care
at all about what they do or how they do
it they let the world wash over them and
barely notice anyone else is even there
Leslie nope is not one of these people
she cares about everything and everyone
in our town I don't know how she does it
people come to her with the pettiest
stupidest problems and she cares like
really actually cares what happens to
them and if you're lucky enough to be
her friend your life gets better every
day she spends every waking moment
thinking of new ways to make her friends
happy there is something wonderful about
seeing someone who has found her true
purpose on Earth for some people I guess
that's being an astronaut or a hot dog
eating champion for Leslie her true
purpose on Earth her true meaning is
making people's lives
better that's what I love about her and
that's why she deserves this
award sincerely
Satan you're getting hugged right now no
I told you not to no stay away
but